you mentioned
kind of going down to 10k like is that
where you're kind of expecting a bottom
like what's kind of your outlook um for
bitcoin and maybe if you have like a
time horizon on that
sure so i i think this is a boring view
but i mean sometimes views are boring um
in my view is that we just chop um and
so chop into probably like into q1 of
next year
and then i think that's the point where
you'll probably get more visibility on
fed policy being uh you know the fed
being done hiking
um you're also gonna eventually get into
the better part of the having cycle
which is which will be helpful
um and then in terms of where we bought
them i mean the tech levels were pretty
good on the way up and they haven't been
very good on the way down
and the reason i think for that is that
texts are a lot of behavior um there's a
lot of behavioral element to technical
analysis
so when it's like a behavioral story on
the way up the levels kind of the the
levels like 69k obviously being the
ultimate meme level
uh work but on the way down there's a
lot more force selling and liquidation
and for selling and liquidation doesn't
care about technicals so
if you're looking for levels like 20
obviously was was that huge breakout um
in whenever that was i guess late 2020
um and we briefly went below that on the
weekend um
down to 17.5 the other level so by
basically buying between 20 and 10 i
mean i know that's a super wide window
but
if you're buying for like longer term
insurance i think that's the window to
buy
the reason i'm looking at like down to
10 is 11 4 is 85 off the highs
and so the in first crypto winter we
were 84 off the highs
and there's a weird um
commonness i don't know that's a word
but commonness to 85 drawdowns in
um
super speculative assets like if you go
through the list of like what are the
big bubbles in the last like 25 years
um so crypto 2017 obviously was one
nasdaq 2000 um housing in 2006
all of those things uh nikkei in 1990
all of those things
went high to low 85 percent um
so
85 percent is 11.4 in bitcoin so i feel
like that's like a reasonable place to
to kind of
think that i i mean i don't think it
goes that far down to be honest but that
would be like worst case scenario